We will begin building our database for
Sunshine by defining
our weather contract.
You might ask, what is a contract?
A contract is an agreement between
the data model, storage, and
views, presentation,
describing how information is accessed.
The agreement in a contract is
implemented in a contract class that
contains a list of constants, typically
database table column names, that
are used to associate data from the data
source within the UI of an application.
So, if this represents the user
interface, then the bottom table
represents the data source that is
being used to feed data to the UI.
Each column in the data source
represents a UI element.
If we search developer.android.com for
the word,
contract, we see that there
are many such contracts to find.
In the Contacts Contract, for example,
we can see that part of the contract
contains a list of column names.
And we can have some sense of what
the contact database looks like.
It has a column for the display name,
flags for the contact, columns for
ID's that are used to link
the contact to data in other tables.
And columns for URI's that point to
images associated with the contact.
In Sunshine,
our contract is used to both create and
interact with our database tables.
Which is why we need to define it at
the start of building our database.
Of course, to create our contract,
we first need to know what we
need to store in the database.